what's up tammy what's up theo quick
question what was your first experience
with tobacco was it that
cowboy killer or is it that smokeless
lip filler gang gang nicotine buzz oh
yeah
and a fellow with a nice body there too
bro
tank top beautiful young fella right
there two arms
yeah where i'm from that's a damn
highlight two arms one eyebrow
oh you show up with two arms dog yeah
he's cute oh somebody's getting married
yes [ __ ]
bro you know uh i've never smoked have
you smoked
no no i mean i've tried it but i've
never like been a smoker
oh yeah i'm six months off of cigarettes
right okay okay
um my grandma and parent everyone around
me growing up
chain smokers no so i you know as a
little kid would like
try nah what did they smoke you what do
you remember what kind
well grandma had to get that jacket
so marlboro
yeah yeah we were always decked out in
marlborough
everything head to toe that's how much
she smoked and you had to smoke like
20 000 worth of cigarettes to get a
jacket yeah and we had closets full
wow you know yeah those jackets yeah
those are some prized pieces yeah
yeah you saw that it was the adults did
the marlboros and the children did those
kool-aid points that were on the back of
the little kool-aid package
and we'd save up and get a pitcher every
year we'd have a family meeting
and we'd do what we wanted to do with
the points you know man
and you could get a little pitcher you
could get a little uh one year we spent
all of them got my little sister a damn
vest dude nothing was a piece of [ __ ]
oh it was it wasn't nice i mean it was
you think a vest would be nice
you would think and damn
it was just i don't know it was almost
like a discontinued uh
um life jacket you know that they were
marketing
his clothing no no they can't do that
they can god they got you they got yeah
they got you they got us butt
but yeah those marlboros and so your
family would just smoke them
oh yeah and what would you do just watch
them yeah oh wow
that was like we had no cable so what
else were we going to do you know
let's watch grandma's cheeks turn you
turn you know
we had channels 10 and 12. we got tired
of soap operas so we just sat there and
watch them smoke
what soap operas were y'all watching oh
my gosh
um we used to watch like the days of our
life just all that [ __ ]
oh yeah literally that's all there was
guiding light as well yep yeah we
watched them all
santa barbara that was an old one my
sister still watches them
i haven't watched them since high school
but she still watches them that's really
interesting dedicated
yeah yeah that can really lead to
loneliness as well
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you
just saw i mean it was okay but
the next video you can watch could be
way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah